um he was in an opposite gang I was in
the opposite gang so he was from one
cartel and I was from the other cartel
me and him got into it and a time when
he would be carrying a gun looking to
kill me personally and of course we were
trying to kill them and
[Music]
we want to establish an amazing mid for
the sake of Allah subhana tala in the
country of Norway click on the link and
donate now for the sake of
allaha brothers and sisters and dear
friends this video was sent to me by far
may Allah bless and preserve him for his
D Works doing around the world and the
enemies of Islam who are dying in their
rage biting their fingers out of Rage
with all the shahad people come to Islam
with the permission of Allah subhana T
and all Praises glory and gratitude
belong to him in this video brother and
sister Subhan Allah somebody who was
going to try to kill brother far in Jah
or he was going to end up killing this
brother Subhan Allah and they both came
to Islam look at this beautiful story
you know what it reminds me of brother
sisters and W it just shows you that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he
prophesized and it is H it reminds me
of wanted to kill
with the stuff that he was say against
the prophet peace be upon him when he
locked up Abu jandal and when he ran in
the Battle of trait of and he took him
back and he was torturing him subh Allah
he wanted to he was boiling his blood
and what did the prophet Muhammad PE
upon him said and om said I will grab
his like take his teeth you know the
front of his teeth or you know his gums
out he's literally saying that he's like
I wish I could do that look at what the
prophet said and look at the story
between aan and brother Richard subh
Allah who's come to Islam and look how
emotional is and he cries why because
the prophet PE upon him said what and
this shows his prophethood this is why
the enemies of Islam and Christians
specifically enemies of Islam of course
the hate hostile ones yeah because not
all the Christians are the same like
Allah say Quan yeah which is what how
did he know the prophet P him told Omar
oh Omar don't say that for verily a day
would come and he may say something that
will make you happy or you're going to
be pleased with and that was fulfilled
in the wars of the apostasy yes the wars
in apostasy yeah and what did say when
the some of them they came to Islam but
after what happened they were starting
to apostas yes after some of them at the
time of ab Bak when he was ruling and
what happened he said and stood up he
said oh qur do not be the last to accept
Islam and the first to
leave and this is they say in the S they
say that this speech that gave he was
known for that is what keep things kept
things stable with the permission of
allaha and indeed saw the prophecy
fulfill here's the video of far and the
story of Richard that's what I'm going
to do I'm not I'm not going to be coming
back in just watch it for yourself
brother and sisters the full video is in
far's Channel brother and sisters that's
all I'm going to say Subhan Allah Allah
subh guides look at these two hostile
gang members wanting to kill each other
and look how the story takes a twist
Subhan Allah and how they come back to
do da they both set out to kill each
other now they have both set out for the
sake of Allah subh what a beautiful
story of Richard let's watch it for
ourself in may Allah bless and preserve
you
guys we're also live on Tik Tok so like
check the Tik Tok link and inshah we're
going to have live on YouTube as well
we're here in Tijuana Mexico richardo is
here is
here the king of aloh is here uh Yousef
is here with me we got some other
brothers masallah so for those watching
live we got a real treat because me and
my armano here we have a lot of history
we're going to talk about a little bit
and we're going to talk about his
history a little bit more than mine CU
you already know who I am right uh but
this is something
that it still till today amazes me how
Allah guides people and how people end
up where like poor dogs man
so me and Richard go way back cuz uh
when I was raised in the US and S Diego
uh as many of you know was in the not
the best neighborhoods and not the best
environment so he got caught up in some
gangs ourselves and Subhan Allah Richard
was from my enemy gang so we were from
the East side and East Clan or East San
Diego they were from Southeast so
Southeast King
Southeast Clan and used to write listo
right lento lento yeah lento uh I used
to write l or shooter from East Side L
from a so we were from enemy gangs and
there were times Subhan Allah
that Us and Them got into it and me and
him got into it and a time when he would
be carrying a gun looking to kill me
personally and of course we were trying
to kill them and many people did die in
the middle of that people from our side
people from their side got shot I got
killed I got stabbed I got jumped I know
I was jumped by them before and uh you
know some of with a choke one of your
guys me and him got into it once at a at
a rave and you know as was a score we
kidnapped him one time and I know yeah
uh and of course we had a lot of our
guys that got killed you know Hench and
others that
are but that's such a crazy thing that
from a time where we were on enemy sides
trying to kill each other till today
that we're brothers in Islam
alhamdulillah here so so tell us about
your life a little bit before Islam I
mean how were you raised were you raised
around the bodyo cartels or were you
raised in nice white neighborhoods
playing soccer yeah bro um moved to San
Diego grew up in Logan Heights right
there low and High Str rest
steps and um
got involved at a really really really
early age with
um with the with the cartel
life like you know everybody else that
gets involved you get involved in human
trafficking drug trafficking gun
trafficking murder kidnapping
extortion and for me and for my family
that was that was normal like normal
business you
know so
um my mom got tired of all that
she you know decided to be a
Christian and um me and my mom used to
give da but the Christian da I don't
know if you remember that one brother at
the Four Corners with the picture of
Jesus upside down yeah Muhammad
abdah my mom and that brother will
always go at it that was the first time
ever in my life I was um no k word no m
word yeah I was I I was I was introduced
to to Islam cuz my mom will always go
out there and debate with that
brother we're going to go so
um grew always grew up in a in a
Catholic um born Catholic how's the
audio raised Christians through my
mom
um know like I said me and my mom used
to go to Logan Heights and give
dawa but even like given the
dawa you
know like it never made sense you know
about you know Jesus being the begotten
Son of God or being God himself you know
cuz you know even going to church you
know you I listen you know so what what
they were preaching wasn't the same as
what I was reading in the Bible
especially not the same as the Ten
Commandments so um
pretty much my mom told me you know
either you accept Jesus or you leave so
at the time I think I was probably like
14 and that's when I went full on with
the gangs the
cartels um started off as a graffiti
artist and right there it came down to a
point where where you had a click up you
had a click up with a gang and every
gang was associated with a
cartel um he was in an opposite gang I
was in the opposite gang so he was from
one cartel and I was from the other
cartel and um so pretty much because I
didn't accept Jesus as my Lord and
Savior I was pretty much my mom kicked
me out so I was just roaming the
streets um at a really early age I
started you know trafficking making a
lot of money getting into a lot of
trouble
um oh man I I get emotional every time I
speak
about that's good man going to this is
the kind of stuff that people hear they
can change their lives we got a brother
here tonight we're going to meet who was
involved in the same stuff just from
watching my video about my life he
became Muslim man so I mean there
there's a lot that I want to say now but
I think we'll probably save here for so
once we get to the m so we don't get cut
off but yeah like I say I was probably
like 14 when I left my house my mom
kicked me out cuz I didn't want to
follow Jesus so I decided to you know
live on my own I was homeless in the
streets for a while doing graffiti gang
banging robbing
people human
trafficking you know and and in that
course you know like you know like
brother Usman said we're we're from from
rival gangs you
know
um
so my story with brother Usman goes was
way way back I don't think I even told
him this one you know uh I didn't know
for a long time who we even was we were
Muslim giving da and I didn't even know
that he was the same guy that you know
were on the opposite ends with I used to
live um right there on 44th in Landis
which was an East Side being from
Southeast what are you doing in our Hood
I lived in east side cuz my mom lived in
east side and I was just you know
roaming around mainly spent my time in
southeast my apologies
you know and uh my first time that I ran
into the brother was um actually on on
44th at
Landis um there's one Chola lady from
East Side locals decided to go stab my
wife in the back with a pencil CU at
that time we were um doing that hustle
in my wife she was like my my
secretary so she comes out wife gets
stabbed in the back I come back
beat the hell out of the lady mopped the
street with her and her two sons came
one was from East Side locals and the
other was from
AK same thing mop the street with both
of them you know and all of a sudden you
know Days Later whatever same you know
because of the problem I remember uh one
of the homeboys that we used to know
back in the days we used to do business
with him he shows up on this low
rider and um all of a sudden I remember
this little
cuz I always when I was looking for him
I always spoke about him as like that
Somali Mexican looking guy you know cuz
he doesn't really look so not Mexican I
didn't know he was you know from where
he was from
so that same
day the brother gets off the car talking
about w w w what's up lowk this and that
and like he said you know he always had
that 357
and I have my
45 so and he doesn't even know this if
it wasn't for my mom that stopped me we
actually would have got into a shootout
right there on 44th at Landis Subhan
Allah can you imagine how Allah writes
the you know that day he had a gun I had
a
gun maybe one of us or both of
us
okay yeah brother like you know like I
was saying you know that it was that
that one day you know that my mother
stopped me said like Richie Richie no I
was like Mom they just stabbed my wife
you know like and and I and that was the
last time alhamdulillah was the last
time I ever saw brother Usman Allah you
know then after that you know a lot of
things happened in my life um I was
always in some kind of a spiritual
journey okay I was um always music's not
from us all right people play in the
neighborhood we don't own the rights to
that music
[Music]
either so like I said you know
alhamdulillah that me and my brother are
past it in Cross cuz Allah subhana wa
ta'ala had a better plan for
us and Allah subhana tal is the best of
planers you
know until today you know I love each
and every one of you for the sake of
Allah everybody all of my brothers and
sisters in
Islam but there's a special place for my
brother with me you
know even
when before my mother passed
away you know before she even accepted
Islam I told her about my
brother and she told
me miho
stick with your
brother cuz God brought you guys back
together cuz he has a greater
plan for you and
him I'm sorry brother that every time I
talk about this even when I'm by my oh
when I'm
reminded you know it
just fills my heart with so much love
for Allah subhana tala for all of you
for my brothers for
Islam you know to me it's still amazes
me you know
that that me that Allah subhana
tala sent him in his journey sent me on
my journey and brought us back together
at this time why only Allah subhana tala
knows but whatever it is is to benefit
the the um to bring the um back together
you know to to prove that that you could
be mortal enemies you know
and you know it was through Islam you
know that now we're brothers we're
together and we're on the same Mission
we're on the same purpose you know which
is to bring daa to bring Islam to these
people right here there's a lot of
people here that are in great need you
know and and
just having Islam being a Muslim it's
like finding something that's so
beneficial or be so selfish of us to
keep it to our and not share it with the
community
you know it's it's like it's something
that's given to you so you can share and
spread you know so that's that's that's
one of the things I'm so grateful to
Allah subhana
tala that um that he brought us back
together e even though before I took my
Shahara we had
probably two
runin the second time was at the the
master remember the one that used to be
a movie theater yeah yeah
that was the second time I think it was
like around the second time that I spoke
to the brother I'm
99.9% sure that it was
him you know and it was because
uh my younger brother had a Muslim
friend and he they were building a um a
jewelry shop it was right right in front
of uh where the master
was so my little brother
his friend was his
homeboy you know and uh he he drove a
crown piig black on black yeah I
remember that you know and um so my
brother told me hey you know I know
there's one
brother and he's a Muslim and his friend
used to be from AK I was like what he's
like yeah like come on you want to go
help me out he's like yeah yeah let's go
I helped you
out we'll go this side to yeah so uh
um so my little brother tells me hey bro
I'm going to go do some work for some
Muslim people over there I was like for
real it's like let's go let's go let's
go I'll go so I go over there and um my
little brother is doing his thing he's
working and I'm doing the
electrical then um I was talking to some
brothers right there just they were
giving me D we're talking and now I
remember this
M the guys coming this way with the
little with the thing suited and booted
you know he comes over we have a chat
you
know we didn't agree on many things you
know that that's the crazy part though
is that I didn't actually put those two
and two together that you were the same
guy from that I remember one time we got
into it I think score was there and
somebody else uh I think you were there
and
somebody got their head cracked from
there and that day you had a gun I had a
gun and I mean Subhan Allah I mean that
close to being dead but then like it was
like 15 20 years later when I ran into
you right yeah 15 20 years later then I
saw you at the park and I didn't know
that this was the same guy right the the
videos are online you can see it was
doing the co time he's masked up and he
comes and he asks the questions we have
this good
conversation and then alhamdulillah we
speak
again and ends up Subhan Allah he
becomes Muslim you know and that's
something amazing you know that Allah
subh guided him through all of that now
what's crazy is that his
pasture you got to tell that story
Pastor Pepe yeah Pepe what go what was
his last name uh Gutierrez
Gutierrez so Richard's not in church
anymore so they asked where's Richard
they're like like oh he met this guy at
a park this Muslim guy he becomes a
Muslim so this pastor guy and again his
mom was a very very practicing Christian
of the
time you know so he's her pastor family
Pastor he decides he's going to come to
B Park and debate me you know and he
made all kinds of you know he was like I
can care of any Muslim in a debate I
live in Saudi Arabia and all this crazy
stuff right so he comes out and the
videos are there on the one message
Foundation Channel Richard coming I
think there's three videos of him before
the shahada those are online but then
his old Pastor coming to debate those
videos are online as well how's the
sound in the
good got a lot of dogs barking in the
background
but yeah he he he he was pretty mad I
remember cuz I I was uh I was in charge
moderator to mute some
people uh to say a moderator mute some
people yeah so I I was actually in
charge of Distributing the food and
doing events for the Youth yeah in
church you know and and all of a sudden
I just stopped going you know I went
over there and I had a conversation with
him I told him hey he like how come
you're not coming he's like no are I'm
Muslim now so we went back at it back
and forth you
know and um he even spoke to my mom yeah
and he told my mom that I guess they
thought I was like Sufi or something
they say no no no no cuz my mom told me
yeah you you go like this and you spin
around and you pray to Ali and all these
others like no no no no no no you know
so people alhamdulillah yeah so that
that's what pretty ticked them off and I
remember he told me oh I go over there
and I debate those Muslims all the time
I was like yeah for real they go oh yeah
I'm going to be there if you want to go
over there and show up you know
and yeah alhamdulillah you know he
showed up too he came and the video's
online he got they got put in his place
alhamdulillah saw him fall apart very
quickly yeah my my mom she just stopped
going to that church I told him you know
that Pastor ish Allah from him coming
and
debating not only did Richard stay in
Islam but his family stopped going to
that church his mother stopped going to
that church I have one of the most
beautiful things ever was when Richard
came to the park one day to give da with
us and this is after the pastor got
defeated watch that video
uh
yeah this mic on the Tik Tok or on the
YouTube YouTube mic is
out let Mech F Tik Talk's fine TI
F so how's YouTube now
good chat post if the sound is good or
not so his
mother was a hardcore Christian her
whole life right like he said the Pastor
came and debated and Subhan Allah from
his loss and from what he was doing his
family stopped going to that church his
mother got away from the church he gave
dawa to his mother Subhan Allah before
her death she accepted Islam and the day
she passed he was coming to the park to
give da and she told him go do your
thing you know and he came out and he
was giving da at the park when she
passed away Subhan Allah may Allah
subhana give her may Allah forgive her
as somebody who became Muslim at the end
of her life and you know this is the the
biggest success you know
alhamdulillah then we after all of this
stuff me and him were here in Tana one
time to give dawa we were sitting right
there and Richard's like you remember me
right and I'm like of course I met you
at the park he goes no no no from before
that you know and I was
like I didn't know you before that and
he's like yeah I dude you did you know I
was lent of from and I was like
whoa it it blew my mind you know how
Allah subhana tala took us from being
mortal enemies to being Brothers in
Islam how that Journey went where it
ended up and Subhan Allah we're here
again in Tijuana Mexico as brothers in
Islam giving dawa bringing the Mah
helping the community inshallah we're
going to go into the mid and sit but
there's a very important story here any
one of us could have given up I could
have given up and just given into the
lifestyle and and where would that end
me up today you know he could have given
up and given into the cartels and the
mafia lifestyle but where would that end
today I can tell you I I have more the
fingers more than the fingers on my
hands I have dead homies people I grew
up with people that I knew since I was 8
years old people that I considered
brothers that I buried right and even
after I left the gang world many of them
got killed even after that people I
didn't even know that I gotten killed
and recently I heard about it so what
did that Mafia gangster life get him
nothing people that say no I was in too
deep I can't get out trust me we were in
deep and we're out and we're Muslim and
we're living it alhamdulillah so take
that lesson and don't ever despair I
mean I would have never imagined
somebody from s from Southeast Logan tra
would be Muslim and my brother but he is
alhamdulillah and a very special brother
to me and a very and with a special
place in my heart I tell you so never
give up on giving dawa to somebody
either don't give up on yourself if you
want to change this is Ramadan you can
do it and if there's somebody you want
to give da to don't give up on them and
don't think oh that guy he he could
never become Muslim no he could you know
Islam net is establishing a Masjid and a
community center if you donate to build
this Masjid Allah will insh build a
house for you in Jenna with bricks of
gold and silver every person who prays
in this Masid every child that memorizes
the Quran you will in share in that
reward donate now guys and do not delay
[Music]